That’s a loon.
And right now, he’s doing something
called wailing.
But this is probably not the first time
you’ve heard that noise.
Here it is in the movie 1917,
as they enter the enemy trench.
In the third Harry Potter movie, as they
climb out of the whomping willow.
In Rick and Morty, when Rick uses
his intergalactic toilet.
You’ll find it whenever a scene
needs to feel a little moody.
"They feared it."
Or eerie.
Or just remind us that we’re in
the great outdoors.
This specific bird call is all over
movies and tv shows.
But, it really shouldn’t be.
If you ever find yourself on birder twitter,
you’ll find a lot of angry tweets like these:
"Can someone please tell movie makers
that loons are not, in fact,
the only bird out there?"
"Hello I am a nature scene in a movie - doesn’t
matter whether it’s habitat appropriate
or not — I’m a Common Loon call."
"Have you ever noticed loon calls in impossible
locations in movies & TV? ...in a jungle?"
SOHL: Watching the movie Harriet.
Only 20 minutes in but I’m giving them kudos.
They were not lazy!
No loon calls yet.
Can you read the first reply on that one?
SOHL: Oh, myself?
SOHL: No! Why, Harriet!
At about the one hour 20 minute mark... they
throw in calling loons.
That's Terry.
He's a research geographer.
But more importantly, he moonlights
on twitter and his blog, as DakotaBirder.
He mostly posts beautiful pictures of birds.
And points out when Hollywood
uses their calls incorrectly.
SOHL: As a birder you just you just can't--
you can't help but notice.
That's because the loon
is a very particular bird.
They’re also called “divers”.
Because they’re really good at diving,
thanks to their dense bones and enormous feet.
They’re also good at something called
penguin dancing.
And scooting across lakes
at astonishing speeds.
This is a map of the common loon’s range:
They mostly stick to Canada and the northern
US -- where there are plenty of lakes for
them to hang out in.
But, they do migrate.
Passing through other US states on their way
to winter along the coasts
as far down as Mexico.
And here’s a very unscientific map
of all of the places
I found a common loon call
in movies and tv.
SOHL: I certainly wouldn't expect a common
loon in Hawaii or in Bolivia or in South Africa.
And geographic location isn’t the only thing
Hollywood gets wrong.
A loon might be found in California.
But not during the summer.
Like Becky, in Finding Dory.
"Lads, meet Becky."
And unlike what this clip from
the TV show Rome implies...
...you'd never find a loon
in the desert.
SOHL: No, they need water.
And quite a lot of it.
SOHL: If you've ever seen a loon try to fly,
it takes them a little while to get going.
They’re actually really clumsy on land.
So, you also wouldn’t find them in
the Vietnamese jungle.
Like in the movie Platoon.
And then there’s this clip, from
Kubo and the Two Strings.
"Golden heron."
SOHL: That happens a lot.
it's one thing to use the wrong bird call
as a background noise
it's another to actually show a picture of
the bird and use a wrong call.
And even if those were loons
that movie takes place in Japan.
Which, is at least on planet Earth.
Unlike Avengers: Infinity War.
SOHL: The big baddie, Thanos, he returns to
his home planet.
SOHL: And so they pan to an overview of the
planet
and the first noise you hear is a common loon.
SOHL: It just ruined the moment.
Some credit a 1981 movie called On Golden
Pond, as the first to use loon calls.
"The loons!"
"The loons."
"Oh look, I've spotted the loons!"
It did feature a lot of loons.
But they used them correctly.
It’s set up north, on a lake,
during the summer.
Really, it’s hard to tell which film kicked
off Hollywood's loon obsession or when.
But it’s pretty easy to figure out why.
SOHL: I mean, it is a scary sound.
I mean, it is just weird.
It's unusual.
In some Algonquin lore,
loons are messengers
and supernatural companions
to legendary hero, Glooskap.
In 1864, naturalist slash philosopher
Henry David Thoreau
said the loon’s call was
“singularly human”.
And in 1913, John Muir, another elaborately
bearded naturalist slash philosopher
called it “strange, sad, mournful and unearthly”.
But the loons aren’t sad
when they’re wailing.
They actually have four calls.
There’s the hoot.
The yodel.
The tremolo.
And the wail.
These two are both used during stressful situations.
When another bird is overstepping his bounds.
Or when some other threat is looming.
If a loon ever looks at you like this
you should probably back away.
The hoot is mostly for chatting
to fellow loons up close.
And the famous wail, it’s basically just
the loon equivalent of a game of Marco Polo.
A way of saying
“Hey! Where is everybody?”
But to human ears even the calmest wail
sounds remarkably melancholy.
I’m no musician, so I enlisted a few of
my coworkers to help explain why.
Like Dave, who’s editing this video.
And Charlie, who hosts the podcast
Switched on Pop.
As well as Vox’s Creative Director, Joe.
Who sent me this video of
his interpretation.
JOE: Now let me show you
what it looks like in Melodyne.
They helped me turn the loon wail into one
of these, a chart showing pitch over time.
In this section, you can see that the loon
makes a jump between two notes.
In complicated musical terms,
this interval is close to a major third
but it also bends into a minor third
right at the end.
JOE: So it starts in a major and ends in a
minor which is extremely funky.
And the loon doesn’t just jump from
note to note like a lot of chirpy birds.
Instead, the notes sort of slide into each other
a feature that Charlie pointed out
you'll also hear in blues and soul music.
Singers like BB King and Muddy Waters and
songs like "Feelin' Good" by Nina Simone.
"Birds flying' high, you know how it feels"
So it’s no wonder the loon wail
is Hollywood’s favorite bird call.
It's a shortcut to a feeling, enhancing a
moment's melancholy, or tension
or sheer remoteness.
SOHL: On the few occasions that I have heard
it in real life, it really is unforgettable.
SOHL: It's just so unlike any other bird call.
SOHL: It's hard that first time you hear it
not to have goose bumps.
It just is such a haunting, unusual sound.
There is a lot more to learn about loons.
They return to the same lake year after year
They do this weird foot waggle
and nobody really knows why.
And they carry their cute, fluffy babies
on their backs.
And their populations are dwindling due to
pollution, human disturbance,
and climate change.
According to one model, the loon is on track
to lose about half of it’s range by 2080.
If you want to learn more about loons, or
what you can do to help protect them
I've linked some organizations devoted to their
conservation in the description of this video.